Magnus and Fabiano are going to be
playing a World Championship match in a
couple of months
how important is the result here at the
same field Cup I think it is very
important for Fabiana to play here
before the world championship match here
because he play obsessed very bad games
against the Magnus this year the
Americans can have that her there but
he's proven it time and again especially
match format it is the best players so
that's why I think for Fabiano it's even
beyond when term just have a good result
in the class goal is a very very
important I think it's for sure the last
time we'll play a game because he's not
playing the Olympiad and after the
Olympian I'm not playing anything else
you know there was some extra motivation
and some extra nerves and some
psychology he's considering we are
playing a match at the end of the year I
don't think it happened by chance that I
think Magnus wanted to play here this
year I almost have the feeling he's
chasing Fabio with yeah he has been
trying to to put me under pressure and
he has been trying very hard to beat me
I mean it's clear that he's putting a
lot of effort into these games he's
probably not too satisfied with his last
tournament in Biel and he probably wants
to kind of end the year before the match
on a good note but I'm also just as
motivated in general magnifique were
competitive in everything not just in
tests in basketball and know and singing
or but not in cooking if you challenge
him even if you challenge him to this
game on the street he would be failure I
think for Magnus there is a little bit
of pressure just from the standpoint he
hasn't played really all that well in
recent events Norway he did kind of I
mean he ended okay but it wasn't a great
event for him bill was a man a disaster
so I mean I think if Magnus doesn't at
least put up a decent result here there
could be some doubts given that they
both arrive in top shape I think it
could be pretty close something like
maybe 6040 or something like that in a
way it's good I think both of them are
kind of picking now and it's exciting to
look forward to and I'm looking forward
to the encounter here
you